From tropical islands to dystopian wastelands
to the farthest reaches of the universe, here's
where you've seen the cast members of Amazon's
music mockumentary Daisy Jones & the Six before.
Daisy Jones lead Riley Keough
has music in her blood. She's
the granddaughter of King of
Rock 'n' Roll Elvis Presley,
as well as the daughter of Lisa Marie Presley and
Danny Keough, both musicians in their own right.
Riley Keough is also no stranger to musical
dramas, as her first on-screen role was the
2010 biopic The Runaways, in which she played
Marie Currie. More big-screen features followed,
including Mad Max: Fury Road,
the crime caper Logan Lucky,
the psychological horror flick The
Lodge, and the A24 black comedy Zola.
As for TV, in 2016 Keough was the lead on
Season 1 of the Starz anthology drama The
Girlfriend Experience, an adaptation
of the 2009 Steven Soderbergh drama
starring former adult film star Sasha Grey.
Keough took another leading TV role in 2022,
this time on the Amazon
thriller The Terminal List.
The band at the center of Daisy Jones
and the Six is led by Billy Dunne,
who's played by English actor Sam Claflin. He's
probably best known for his turns as Finnick in
The Hunger Games series. He previously made his
big screen debut back in 2011 as Philip Swift,
the young missionary captured by Blackbeard in
Pirates of the Caribbean: On Stranger Tides.
Sticking with the franchise work, Claflin also
played William in Snow White and the Huntsman and
its sequel. His other notable cinematic credits
include the survival drama Adrift, and the romance
flicks Me Before You and Love Wedding Repeat. More
recently, he starred in Netflix's Enola Holmes,
in which he assumed the iconic role
of Mycroft, the eldest Holmes sibling.
And over on the small screen, from 2019 to
2022, Claflin was a regular cast member on
the British crime drama Peaky Blinders as
real-life politician Sir Oswald Mosley.
"We deal in reasoned
principle, argument, and fact."
Former model Camila Morrone stars
on Daisy Jones as Camila Dunne,
wife of bandleader Billy. If you know her
name but not her work, it's probably because
of her controversial relationship with Leonardo
DiCaprio, which ended shortly after she turned 25.
Morrone hasn't starred in anything huge yet, but
she has shown up in a few notable movies. In 2018,
she was one of the leads in the indie stoner
comedy Never Goin' Back, and she played the
daughter of Bruce Willis' vigilante character
in the remake of Death Wish. And in 2020,
she showed up in Valley Girl, a remake of
the 1983 Nicolas Cage film of the same name.
With a leading role on Daisy Jones, Morrone is
putting her modeling work behind her, as she
focuses instead on her budding Hollywood career.
As she told The Wall Street Journal in 2020,
"I think it's hard for the world and also
the industry to be able to see you as both."
Model turned actress Suki Waterhouse stars in
Daisy Jones and the Six as keyboardist Karen,
a headstrong musician determined to break
the mold of women in show business. She's
yet to have a true breakout role, but she
has appeared in plenty of notable films,
including the 2014 romantic dramedy
Love, Rosie, which also featured Sam
Claflin. She also played Kitty Bennet in
2016's Pride and Prejudice and Zombies.
Waterhouse finally secured a leading role in
the The Bad Batch, in which she fought off a
gang of deranged cannibals in a dystopian future.
And then in 2019, she could be seen in Detective
Pikachu as Ms. Norman, the genetically modified
Ditto, and in the 2021 indie horror flick Seance.
"It's been a long time in the making, so we're,
we're, I think we're ready at this point."
While several actors from Daisy Jones
started out as models, Nabiyah Be's
first career makes her even more suited for
a musical drama. She stars as Simone Jackson,
best friend to Daisy Jones. Though Be's
career in Hollywood has barely begun,
it's her life as a singer, songwriter, and
Broadway actress that proves her bona fides
Be has thus far appeared in just one feature
film, but it's one of the biggest of all time,
as she had a small role in 2018's superhero
epic Black Panther. She played Linda Johnson,
a highly-trained black ops soldier and
girlfriend of the villainous Erik Killmonger.
Hailing from Brazil, Be has received accolades
for her stage work, including the Drama Desk
Award for her performance in School Girls; or The
African Mean Girls Play. She also played the role
of Eurydice in the Off-Broadway version of the
Tony-winning Broadway musical Hadestown. Daisy
Jones is her first major TV role, as she plays
a disco star who mentors the title character.
Among the relative newcomers of the Daisy Jones
cast is Will Harrison, an Ithaca native who spent
most of his young adult life in Massachusetts
before attending Carnegie Mellon School of Drama.
In 2019, at the age of 22, Harrison appeared
on an episode of the CBS political drama Madam
Secretary. A year later, he starred in
the indie drama This is a Film About My
Mother. On Daisy Jones, he plays Graham
Dunne, younger brother of Billy and the
group's lead guitarist and co-founder. It's
a larger and meatier role than Harrison has
ever played thus far in his career. He stands
to gain serious attention from the series,
as a strong performance could spotlight his talent
on a larger stage and result in his big break.
"That's the story that I had heard."
Sebastian Chacon may have one of the biggest
bodies of work among the lesser-known Daisy Jones
cast members, as he's shown up in some of today's
biggest TV hits. He started his Hollywood career
with a small part on an episode of Madam Secretary
before moving on to the USA techno-thriller Mr.
Robot. From there, he showed up for a single
episode on a bunch of other shows in a wide
range of genres, including the Batman prequel
Gotham and CBS' Sherlock Holmes series Elementary.
Chacon eventually began snagging recurring roles,
including two episodes of Pose, a three-story
stint on Tales of the City, and finally the part
of Fly Rico on Penny Dreadful: City of Angels.
And as for the big screen, he had a key role
in the 2022 indie thriller Emergency. Now that
he's a series regular on a hotly anticipated
show, he can finally call himself a star.
In the role of guitarist Eddie Roundtree is
little-known British actor Josh Whitehouse,
who boasts a modest but impressive resume. If
you've seen him before, it was likely on the
BBC historical drama series Poldark, on which
he was a main cast member for Seasons 3 and 4.
The 2020 remake of Valley Girl was a starring
vehicle for Whitehouse, as he played Randy,
the '80s punk rocker who becomes the object
of desire for a Los Angeles teenage girl.
The previous year he starred opposite Vanessa
Hudgens in the Netflix holiday romance movie
The Knight Before Christmas, in which he played a
14th-century knight transported to the modern day.
"Love is the first and foremost
of all knightly virtues."
In addition to Daisy Jones, Whitehouse is
due to star in the upcoming The Happy Worker,
as well as the animated film
Ozi: The Voice of the Forest.
Tom Wright plays Teddy Price, the
producer at the record company who
first brings Daisy Jones to the attention
of The Six and sticks by their side as
they rise to the top of the charts.
A longtime veteran character actor,
Wright is the kind of face you know you've
seen but might have trouble placing.
Starting his career out in the early '80s, it's
possible you know Wright as the titular hitchhiker
on the Creepshow 2 segment "The Hitchhiker."
You may also recognize him from any number
of '80s and '90s favorites, as he racked up
credits in plenty of movies from those decades,
including Tales From the Hood. As for TV,
Trekkies will no doubt remember him as the
ill-fated transporter creation that
was doomed to die on the Star Trek:
Voyager episode "Tuvix." Meanwhile, sitcom
fans may remember him from four episodes
of Seinfeld as Mr. Morgan, the skeptical
Yankee Stadium coworker of George Costanza.
After appearances on a number of hit
dramas, Wright became a series regular
on the BYUtv series Granite Flats, as
FBI agent Ezekiel Scott. More recently,
he starred on the 2020 Netflix sitcom Medical
Police, on which he played CDC Director Patten.
There may be only one man more important to Daisy
Jones and the Six's success than producer Teddy
Price, and that would be manager Rod Reyes.
He's played by the legendary Timothy Olyphant,
who's enjoyed a career bringing to life charming
rogues and swaggering do-gooders. He's something
of a modern-day John Wayne, as he's best known
for playing a couple of iconic lawmen. First
there was US Marshal Seth Bullock on the
groundbreaking HBO Western Deadwood. That
led to his starring turn as Raylan Givens,
the sharp-shooting, steely-eyed gunslinging
marshal on FX's crime drama Justified, which
is easily his most iconic work to date.
Olyphant then showed off his funny side beginning
in 2017 on the Netflix zombie sitcom Santa Clarita
Diet alongside Drew Barrymore. Then he returned
to the role of a marshal on Season 4 of the
anthology series Fargo. After playing himself
on the sitcoms The Good Place and The Grinder,
he played a marshal once again, but
this time in a galaxy far, far away,
on the Star Wars Disney+ series The
Mandalorian and The Book of Boba Fett.
As for the movies, Olyphant's most notable roles
include James Stacy in 2019's Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood and Mickey in Scream 2 all the way
back in 1997. And he's set to have a busy 2023,
as he's due to return to the role of Raylan Givens
for the miniseries Justified: City Primeval.
"You might want to factor them items into the
equation before you decide
what you gonna do next."
If you're a fan of
crime dramas, you no doubt know the name, or at
least the face, of Jacqueline Obradors. She has
a recurring role on Daisy Jones as Lucia, but
for the past several decades she's been a small
screen stalwart, including on a couple of the
most well-regarded crime dramas of their day.
From 2001 to 2005, Obradors played
Detective Rita Ortiz on NYPD Blue.
She appeared in 80 episodes of
the series, which led to guest
appearances on plenty of other shows. She
eventually landed another regular role,
this time as another detective on the Amazon crime
procedural Bosch, beginning with season five.
Though she's always been more of a TV actor,
Obradors does have a few notable movie roles
on her resume. Fans of the 2001 animated Disney
sci-fi adventure Atlantis: The Lost Empire may
recognize her as the voice of teenage mechanic
Audrey. She also appeared in the Wesley Snipes
action thriller Unstoppable in 2004 and in 1998's
action-adventure comedy Six Days, Seven Nights.
Another relative newcomer to Hollywood,
Ayesha Harris plays Bernie on Daisy Jones,
which is her biggest part to date. A barber in
her pre-acting days before she left Long Beach,
California, Harris made her
on-screen debut in 2017,
when she appeared on an episode of The CW
horror series Two Sentence Horror Stories.
While Harris' role on Daisy Jones is a
potential turning point in her career,
it's not as if she's never been on a hit series.
She's mostly had minor blink-and-you’ll-miss-'em
roles, but maybe in 2022 you noticed her when
she made a delivery on an episode of the ABC
sitcom Abbott Elementary. She also made
her big screen debut that same year in the
anthology film Tell it Like a Woman, which was
nominated for Best Original Song at the Oscars.
2023 is shaping up to be an even bigger year
for Harris. In addition to playing Bernie,
she's also signed up for the
Netflix series Glamorous,
on which she'll appear alongside
Kim Cattrall in the story of a young
gender nonconforming queer person who gets
a gig working for a renowned makeup artist.